[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In an
existing GCP project,
click the Cloud Shell icon on
the blue menu bar at the top
to show the Cloud Shell frame
at the bottom of your window.
Type in gcloud projects list.
Choose one of your projects
to use for this quick start
and note the project ID.
Type gcloud config set project
followed by your project ID.
Next, get the code for
the sample App Engine app
from GitHub using the link
included in the Quick Start.
Now go into the newly
created directory
and deploy this app
with gcloud app deploy.
You now have an App
Engine app running.
And you can check
it in your browser
to see that it's working.
After you authenticate,
it greets you by name.
Perfect.
Next, you'll add Identity Aware
Proxy in front of this app.
Go to the Navigation
menu to Security
to Identity Aware
Proxy, or click
the link in the Quick Start.
Under all Web Services,
then under App Engine app,
you'll see the app
you just deployed.
Select it.
On the right side
panel, click Add Member.
Add the email address
of a person or group
and choose IAP-secured web app
user for role under Cloud IAP.
Then Save.
Use the IAP slider next
to the App Engine app line
to turn on IAP for this app.
That account will still
see the same welcome
if logged in when browsing.
Another account will get
an access denied error
as intended.
Congratulations!
Your application is now
protected by Identity Aware
Proxy and is only accessible
to the people you authorize.
[MUSIC PLAYING]